[Music]
19 states have suceeded the United
States Army ramps up activity the White
House issued warnings to the Western
forces as well as the Florida Alliance
the three term president assures the
uprising will be dealt with swiftly let
me know if you want to try anything off
are you guys aware there's like a pretty
huge civil war going on all across
America we just try to stay out with
what we see on the news seems like it's
for the
[Music]
best
citizens of America the so-called
Western forces of Texas and
California have suffered a very great
defeat at the hands of the United States
military Mr President do you regret the
use of air strikes against American
citizens we're moving to theca today we
need to go down there they shoot
journalists alls side in the capital
every Instinct in and he says this is
death
what every time I survived the war zone
I thought I was sending a warning home
don't do
that but here we are there's some kind
of misunderstanding
here we American
okay okay what kind of American are
you you don't
know
the Western forces will reach the White
House on July 4th oh my god get in the
get in
the move move
move you're going to hang back I'm not
hanging back one
nation under God
indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
go go go go
go God Bless
[Applause]
[Music]
America
Hi Well lookie lookie she is the perfect
fit I promise did she even see you she
was about
to what are you doing don't do
this
[Music]
no
hi oh God so starts
this is just so exciting what is
happening well that's a perfectly
understandable question given num I'm an
if get it imaginary
friend our kids grew up so we need new
ones you could save all of us all of
whom and don't say
ifs let him say it or I think his head
may actually
explode
f
thank you you ready for
this there's no telling who's behind
that door
today we have to help them yes we
do
I I'm not going to ask you again put
some pants on you're freaking everyone
out starting to see why I live
alone
chat kind of a kid creates an invisible
[Music]
if don't uh don't don't look him in the
eye which one you know damn well which
one
thanks for doing this it really means a
whole
[Music]
lot
truee
foreign
whatever you have to
do however long it
takes promise me you'll find your way
home
fosa give me this
promise
[Music]
I
L and
gentlemen start your
engines
ieros the darkest of
Angels the question is
do you have it in you to make it
[Music]
epic what's your name Kyo sweet I'm Mr
Miller I'm assuming that you got one of
these before I read the whole list well
there's 12 books on that list Bary
heart what is an
adult I'm
18 languishing in the Wilds of nowhere
Tennessee break curse don't you get
scared walking through those woods I'm
the scariest thing in
there never knew I could be speechless
yes I want you to write a short story in
the style of your favorite author are
you offering me a special treatment Mr
Mill well
uh John here is prepping her to be his
Transcendent is she pretty oh she's
talented damn even worse what are you
bring about I'm un inspired I've had no
achievement make him love you I'll set
fire to the whole
place I don't know
she's opened her mouth to say
[Music]
something but the words fell
away why did you write this this is
inappropriate write what you know is
what you said if you don't rewrite this
I'll have to fail
you I'm dare
you it's like he's been living in Grays
scale and you're the first thing he's
ever seen in
color feel
you are the adult show some
responsibility you're my student and I'm
your teacher that's
all if she can convince them that
something happened between us I could
lose my job it's not all you could lose
you're going to ruin his life burn it
down it down it
down in your own words how did it start
said I was a good
[Music]
kid it is time to take the next step on
your journey I'm not going to be the
Dragon Warrior anymore you will advance
the spiritual leader of The Valley Of
Peace inner
peace inner peace keep your surup off my
tur dinner please dinner with peas in a
sesame swy glaze this is not working at
[Music]
all Kum big
fan once I possess the Kung Fu of every
Master villain no one will dare question
my power not even the Great Dragon
Warrior who's that the most powerful
shape-shifting sorceress the Cameleon
how do I find this the chameleon I'm
going to lead you right to her front
door
yeah it was against an
army then we'll just have to get an army
of our
own what is this place the best Crooks
and criminals live here you're a wanted
criminal you sound surprised is it
surprising now you kids be careful of
those
fireworks violence makes our tummies
tingle why should we help you we can
take down the chameleon together being
the Dragon Warrior it's who I
am what do I know about being a
spiritual leader what is it you're
holding a cookie you were chosen to
become something more than you already
are how should we do this quick and
painless or slow and painful slow and
painful you finally met met your match
chameleon We're Not So Different you and
I SC stand back I'm going to kick my
[Music]
butt it's okay I'm here I'm here it's
been a while since you've had one of
those nightmares tell me what was it
about it's only
fragments nothing's
[Music]
clear you've been fighting the hinin for
decades
lo my family's been fighting them for
centuries your blood comes from Dukes
and great
houses here we're
equal what we do we do for the benefit
of
[Music]
all I'd very much like to be equal to
you maybe I'll show you the
way deal with this Prophet send ass
assassins fade rathera he's psychotic
[Applause]
I see possible Futures all at once and
in so many futures or enemies Prevail
but I do see a way there is a narrow way
[Applause]
through
[Music]
my allegiance is to you you believe
me this is a form of power that our
world has not yet seen the ultimate
[Music]
power I want you to know I will love you
as long as I
breathe you will never lose me as long
as you stay who you are consider what
you're about to do for a tra is Skyland
this prophecy is how they enslave
us you are not prepared for what is to
[Music]
come
when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories not
Memories new
things I see
everything
that is
not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful
day
well I hold a brick in my
hand I know exactly what it is and what
it will
do form is its
function that gives me
peace can I help you I'm the brick layer
sir this is urgent what am I looking at
Victor radic we need to bring Vil out of
retirement what do you want and an old
friend stop by to say hello someone's
trying to Blackmail the CIA you can
bring down our entire Global
Network that's why I want you to go to
Greece to fix it with her it's a big
assignment for you first time in the
field no
supervisors I'm the supervisor of course
you are
so what's our move have to find him and
end
this you should have stayed where you
were cuz now that you're
back it's going to be hard for you to
leave again
[Music]
clearly
I warned you not going to get
involved you can't hide from you I'll
never ever stop
[Music]
coming oh little less colone next time
yes
[Music]
dear
we're going on a Manhunt not building a
chimney never do a job without my
tools America loves a
superstar I'm Jason 2 J's jennies I was
a football all Legend but once you reach
the Mountaintop of greatness everybody
wants to see you
fall two days this guy smoked damn you
plad guilty to charges of speeding and
damage to city property I'm recommending
community service with the Long Beach
Recreations department I thought I was
getting like some Martha Stewart kind of
treatment you too good for the community
that raised you from the of the sea to
the do do
I am football legend Jason 2 J's
Jennings your new head coach Legend let
me get a picture what y'all will put for
Twitter some of y'all going to get some
girlfriends with this right
here ke Karine Jason I've been trying to
get back in touch with you for years I
know you've been thinking about me and I
know you've been trying to get in touch
with me is that pretty much right you
just put a gun in my head relax Jay the
safety was on oh no it wasn't on what
imagine that
before we can be the best we got to
master the
fundamentals pretty boy you missing pass
after pass you got on all that sweet ass
swag the next time you come out here
acting like a fake ass rapper we going
to kick your ass off the field stop
acting like you got an album coming
out JJ how you liking this game coach
this is a mess I don't know what I'm
doing do you remember what you were like
when you showed up freshman year you
were paying in the ass I don't want
nobody nothing sound just like me if you
really want to win a game stop pushing
away your
team let's
go it look like a black princess L
underdogs on three underdogs on Me 1 2 3
what's my
[Music]
name I got your masc right here be
killer and srer two dos for two G I
found them chained up in the back of the
winner
snitches for most of human
civilization we believed that life could
only exist
on the surface of our
planet what else were we wrong
about welcome to my
worldon you come on
in this world has has more
secret than we could possibly imagine
Miracles
I
still now and
[Music]
then what is
that that's not
Kong what could have done
this
Kong can't stop this on his
own he won't be
alone
welcome to my
world is that a mini
Kong hey there Feller heard you're a
Gravedigger said he buried a few famous
people buy you
drink corac to
show ready to go Dad all right on me all
your pants on I want to go with you
Daddy please I'll bring you back
something special and maybe that gingham
dress I picked out no
maybe they call themselves The Rufus
Buck
gang some say that they were senseless
Killers some say they were haunted by
wild Spirits all right I'm Federal
Marshals their reign of terror begin
with the old Palmer
family one of the armor she's gone heck
wants to find her before something worse
happens let them s they ass we going to
take them fools out too and we's going
to get this back in
blow I'm US Marshal heck Thomas this God
is my witness we will see Justice Done
bet Trail them boys to wherever they
hold up and then I'm going set Ambush
for them go ahead and turn around for me
the great heck Thomas you going to be
remembered as a murdering coward you
going to have to be remembered as a man
who gets done in by roof his buff
my Mur that
man you can never be what's so special
about this ruus they think he's destined
to be a great
leader I'm going to make y'all Kings of
this new world anything y'all want it's
going to be yours for the
taken this end
now
they can never get enough
I never in the face of death I remain a
renegade how it in was there some big
gunfight or
something w w w easy get your money's
worth okay we are recording the World
Rally Championship has become the number
one TV sport in the world we're joined
by lacha team manager chare Fiorio reing
is like a war and I'm the commander of
an
army Walter H You' got a competitive car
this year yeah very incredible Car
Central engine light car very special
materials fourwh Drive no no no no two
wheel drive you can't beat them with a
normal
car yes we
can if you drive
it give me one good reason why I should
accept because we are The Underdogs Jo
ch ch thinks he can challenge us without
a four-wheel drive they better was Ice
what you
think you still think that the Germans
are only technology in an organization
don't you don't believe all the cliches
F you welcome to the opening of the 51st
Monte Carlo
rally rallying is a dangerous sport does
anything frighten you one thing
losing
go
[Applause]
now we have the second stage in
TOS let's go with that car you will
never win against me the drivers why do
they risk their
lives death is afraid of those who
pursue
it the win I'll do whatever I have to do
I'll only do six races take it to
Le
watch without even play it all out in
one last stage Walter you must recover
10 seconds it's now never push push
push you okay I'm just thinking about
what
winning you have to save yours and our
reputation the DEA murders in Silverado
remember that
yeah two undercover agents killed in a
drug buy we're
DEA I got the marshals to agree to send
you down and bring those two witnesses
back
[Music]
here sometimes I mess around with movie
lines you're looking at me mhm there
nobody else around
[Music]
here
got a doctor fix you up the right
way this is my brother it's dangerous
the longer we here the more danger for
your family johon has a few lives left
he's a strong
one she can help solve who killed those
DEA agents in America we can protect you
can
I saw what happened that night and they
know
it so who do you know that you trust
that you can
call so many questions my
friend if you want to fight with the
wolves you got to be a
[Music]
wolf we are the
12 each with a unique power meant to
protect this
world but we need you for what's
[Music]
coming are you ready to begin your
training don't what you can't teach
don't talk what you can't walk okay hold
hold on you'll be faster I know who I am
I know where I land stronger than most
humans wait wait wait hey hey
no I'm more powerful than you could
possibly
imagine I'm going stay in
the wait how did you know I was going to
survive I didn't so what are you my
sidekick no not
[Music]
exactly
mess with a tiger you get the claws what
that's not a thing yes it is no it isn't
no one says that tigers
[Music]
do bo bo
United
Nations you give me
this
[Music]
you caning me just Stu
foree
fore
for
Fore
bab
spee
foreign
for
[Music]
ni Peter
Barrett excuse me my name is
Sophia and my mom called you Peter
biometric watch contains a hard drive
with sole access to his contacts stolen
Intel and we want it all back she wanted
you to find someone named Peter my
name's Mark I wish I could be more help
you were CIA like my mom right you're a
really good painter oh hey kid stop
those are private this is her this is my
mom so you do know
her go upstairs BL Dar lefts the
bathroom lock the door and get in the
tub what's
[Music]
happening you are Peter Barrett how'd
you find me
what do you know about Peter Barrett the
painter Bo murdered eight federal agents
in Cold Blood what I am looking for
someone it's me Peter where are you can
I trust you two agents showed up my
doorstep today asking about
you he's hiding
something and the only one them could
protect you tell me about the people who
came to kill me she thinks that you're
in possession of something that poses a
major thre threat to our national
security I'm going to find out who took
your mother away from you and then and
then he'll do what he does mind if I
borrow a few
things
I don't want to do this
kid my dad he
died I'm the solicitor at your father's
estate my dad owned this
place I don't have any memories with him
this is all I have right
now
if you're watching this then I'm already
[Music]
dead this property comes with a special
tenant you're the one thing that stands
between her and the outside world you're
joking why is that come out come out
wherever you
are
Iris we shouldn't be
here what is
she she has the power to bring back the
Dead I want to see her money's really no
object I want to talk to my
wife she only gives you 2
minutes Sarah after that she's in
control what's going
on we are not safe
here how do I control
her this isn't something you can
control
I'm going to kill you you can't kill
her you cannot let her out of the
basement
most of you are aware that you live in
reality parallel to many versions of
your Universe I've gathered you all to
save your
worlds that does not look good you got
that
right the threat is
real I was on one of the Earths that was
swallowed by this wave well who we have
here I come from a parallel Earth we
look down on super villains
welcome our newly formed team of Heroes
the Justice
[Applause]
League drained the power from
them thank you Justice
League something's about to happen
something
major I am Harbinger this is the thing
yeah I figured you each possess the
skills strength and speed to save your
Universe Great
Scott what's happening the universe it's
all Vanishing
look this is it I won't let you go is it
as bad as it looks yes 5 4 3 2
[Music]
1 Professor Le Dr FR have given you up
for lost you Yi is my personal assistant
really well if a patient is calm y
always stretches out at my feet but if a
patient is agitated y he stands at my
side what should I make if he's running
away at the side of me ah well he's also
fanatic about
punctuality well you have a wonderful
home my daughter Anna tried the best to
replicate our home in Vienna forgive me
but why would you come here to see me if
you disagree so passionately with My
Views to make you realize that you're
wrong
well that God you've insisted all your
lives to the very concept of God is
ludicrous yes why someone of your
Supreme intellect could certainly
abandon truth and then Embrace a
ludicrous dream an Insidious lie well I
wholeheartedly disagree well of course
you disagree you have to disagree
otherwise the entire structure of your
childish Faith would collapse into a
rubble why does religion may bring to
science but science refuses to make room
for religion oh please you're breaking
my heart cuz they hide behind their
ignorant you hide behind your ignorance
I think that you're afraid to feel
emotions at all is that your final
diagnosis fascinating I don't know you
don't know well finally finally finally
we're making
[Applause]
progress rely to yourself thinking that
you can control death the way you
control your world and your
daughter Anna is dedicated to the
science is she seeing someone she has no
time for relationships I'm worried about
my father he has no one there must be
someone me that's my girl truth is
you're terrified we're all terrified see
you bury your doubts you bury your
memories of the war but at the core of
your being we're all cowards before
[Music]
death
don't keep me
waiting you keep your head held high
just like Mom to
us what have I say
go you got to stay
hell no there's going to be some changes
made this ain't me hush we need to look
like we
belong it's time toce the world hell
no
h oh miss you look good h
no kill them don't be no fool don't
waste your
time any man that hurts you
a I had enough for
you oh you got to say you need to say
you better say the woman at this table
of lost demise now you're
preaching
hell
[Music]
no hell hell hell no you and all that
disrespect your head to the door when I
do my dance only time I'm on the flow
and I don't even let a man take me that
low coming from
the Mounds
[Applause]
torso
I have a daughter that's her see if you
can find her for me will you are you
sure let me know she's happy I think
I've earned that much from
you if I was on the outside I'd be down
there
tonight how do you know right I have to
be an excon man has no friends left in
the real world the search for the Escape
prisoner is still underway
Ray he has a
vendetta I built a home here Mommy come
on come come on we got to go Mommy where
are we going on an
adventure how do he convince you to do
this I was helping out a guy who helped
me you show the devil right to my
doorstep what that is he coming to
collect from
you you say I brought the devil well the
devil doesn't come for the innocent
needed a little
nudge your buddy is coming to kill
me he took
her you could just played your
part it's your turn to wake up
[Applause]
afraid
so are you
ready ready for
[Music]
what we are are able to go into other
people's dreams four men and a maiden
must complete the games a maiden really
pretty sexist
book when Hallow's Evas do make your
greatest wish come true
you you really don't have to she's
already a part of this okay she's a
natural
dreamer I wish I
[Music]
wish your dreams shall soon be true but
your nightmares will be
[Music]
too it's stop
breathing and if we don't do this I
die
[Music]
must be way to stop
this pum
we hand the ramp Lo at the
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
turun
dear
[Music]
f